apa
more
my mother my phrases over there can be
explained to go to visit my parents about her
yes anyway many trabi had
come to
see the ku'damm we should now just drink beer
[music]
like no other he has that france
after the war  minted charles de
gaulle he died exactly 19 years ago today
and here are the
lottery numbers when the german lottery
block was drawn yesterday the
following winning numbers were determined and the
lottery numbers from the gdr from the day before
[music]
thank you very much that was great you got it
all  taken out of the computer at
home all the sounds everything you
heard yes yes otherwise it doesn't work
but i think you should
n't overestimate the computer even though it's a
practical one like a recording device
[laughter]
[applause]
[music]
the situation in gdr  had
already come to a head
and we knew that due to the
massive upheavals in the gdr government, too,
the pressure
had increased
to respond to the demands of the population since
the opening of the borders in hungary
one noticed that it was about what was happening
something was in the air
[music]
the departure of gdr citizens
continued unabated in the last 24
hours more than 11,000 people came via
the border of the cssr to bavaria
where does the mood barometer in
the population suggest according to the latest
information from the zk a survey
today in east berlin
actually went from one swoon to the
other
but isn’t that interested anymore
because he’s actually gone
so i’m him  opinion that it is
very sad at the moment that there is a lot of
talk and nothing is happening nothing
noticeable is happening
imagine the whigs
one and a half years before the us talk show rüdiger lentz you are the
head of the studio in washington watching
what is happening in eastern europe and
the gdr from a distance of 6000
kilometers closed
sydney like you in washington
for me two things are very very
touching  america is coming the
americans have a core sentence in the
american constitution says how the
people
that is now being practiced in a murky way like
that of the new way of dealing with democracy that
the americans are tremendously interested in
and that's the morning and the name is
laid 17 10
well but ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to rias tv called
we have a completely normal news
are made on rias tv from 6 p.m. to 6:30 p.m
we didn't want to be given out in the first place but we did
n't want to be honest in the end it doesn't come out as
far as I know it's immediately immediately that was in fact the confusing statement by
schabowski what that would mean in the
end
and that's exactly what it's all
about  led him to do it very much,
so to speak, with a certain
time delay, a certain de  lay the
people noticed,
so to speak, what that means, so to speak, that the
imperviousness of the wall has been lifted
[applause]
co-
expression of mauerfall open so in the
early morning broadcast I was then sent to the
Bornholm Bridge a
border crossing that is normally only for the
best lina and  federal citizen in the
other direction namely in the direction
of east berlin is destined this
border crossing was opened in the other direction today
because he knows that so many have
used the opportunity and how
did the word get around
quite simply i found out my friends on
tv i was just in
the kitchen you have broad chest yes i
had to but first message
normal looks to
reassure me about it and immediately
made me worried it was perfectly
clear to me that this would be part of the
story
and we were not only there but
were really right in the middle of it
history i have mine once  in my
paralyzed wish
to go through this brandenburg gate and come the
other side i won't drive in either
[music
] the color comes
so it was very difficult
to curb your own emotions, so to speak,
with these pictures what will happen in
a situation like  we also
experienced it here that day when
one of the young border guards loses his nerve
there is an
uncontrollable chain reaction that
can no longer be stopped
even today we have to state that
looking back it is bordering on a miracle
that this peaceful
revolution came about  the mix of joy
still, in any word, a
fitness test of love of country
music [music]
here in this bar on the corner of
kudamm and joachimstaler straße the first stop of your
tour through the west after half past
one on kudamm at midnight it was
still quiet here almost an hour and a half
later
masses of people cheer and applaud the gdr citizens as they
trot
applause broke out outside to the several
hundred people waiting when at 11:45 p.m.
here at the chausseestrasse border crossing the
first car from east berlin, of course a
trabi, was allowed to cross the border a
father had heard the news and
spontaneously went with his daughter on a
nightly visit to the western part of the city
decided
then was the most important income
street we had where all the big
companies all the big labels have settled
a waiter from a restaurant in
prenzlauer berg had
brought most of his guests with him we spent
the whole evening is now of
course word got around first was that
the border is supposed to be opened tomorrow will
be stamped by council or with a visa and
that's why it came so far that everyone
can dare as they want and we
actually drove to the square in the direction of the border
, i.e. in the direction of Bornholmer Straße,
doesn't even notice the colleagues
claim the news we  now
sell come hopefully mo  early
afternoon
[music] was
what the borkener moning thinks a piquant
welcome engines like running
casting camp west welcome
good morning ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the rias tv
breakfast television yesterday will undoubtedly go down in history as the
day
on which the iron  the curtain was
raised in germany
several tens of thousands of citizens from east
berlin and the gdr took advantage of the opportunity today
to cross the borders to west berlin
without a passport and without a visa at 8
a.m. this morning should be the end of
it but that hasn’t happened until now  1
p.m. we will inform you about the
latest developments in berlin
first the news
what a day ladies and gentlemen
rias tv has only good news
for you continue with news the gdr
wants to open further crossings
between east and west berlin in the evening i
give now  a message from the agency ap
continues to be so sensational  is that
at the moment i am really passing it on
with reservations az
press is reporting at the moment that the
gdr border authorities are starting to tear down the wall
we will endeavor
to check this report in the village to see
whether it is correct and then
in the course of the  inform shipment about it